welcome to the Macmillan report I
Marilyn woke your host and today our
guest is Professor Paul Saban an
assistant professor of environmental
history professor Saban's research and
teaching focus on us environmental
history energy politics and political
and economic history including natural
resource development in the American
West and overseas his book crude
politics examines how politics and law
shaped growing dependence on petroleum
in California and the nation today we'll
talk with Professor Sabin about how
history can prepare us for the climate
crisis and energy transition welcome
professor savin Thank You maryland's a
pleasure to be here in your latest si
you argue that historians can help us
prepare for the climate and energy
crises give us your perspective sure
well in the most recent work I'm really
trying to figure out what role
historians might have to play in
addressing the climate problem and also
the energy issues and I come at it from
the perspective that we've been aware of
the climate problem for many years since
the there's a church of the jewels
Chinese report in 1979 so really the
last three decades we've really been
aware of the broad scope of the climate
problem but we haven't been able to
solve solve the problem and so in my
recent work I'm re i argue that one of
the reasons that this is the case is
that the problem has been addressed
primarily by lawyers and scientists and
engineers and economists and really that
the energy problem its nature is one
that is is not actually a technical
problem as a social problem and
historians have a lot to offer in
thinking about climate and energy in
that context and so on the essay I'm
exploring some of the insights of
history might bring to bear to the
climate problem and energy issues okay
so what are some of the lessons that
historians can offer us well I think the
first lesson is that is that history
really is embedded in a lot of the
conversations around climate change and
in in that that as people try to develop
solutions to these problems they're
they're using his
story yet at the same time historians
haven't been involved in the
conversation so some of the examples
might be for instance right now there's
a current debate in Congress about
whether to pursue a cap-and-trade bill
for for carbon dioxide emissions which
would set an overall cap for for these
emissions and then allow industries and
businesses to trade those underneath
those cap so that's one idea and then
the other is to pursue attacks that
would raise the price of carbon carbon
emissions and i think that the this
debate has been profoundly influenced by
historical interpretation of the early
1990s when the clinton administration
pursued an energy tax and i think ours
widely believed that the 1994 a
republican takeover of congress was was
in part a reaction to do this among
other things but about the get the
energy taxes were a significant factor
and by contrast the there were a series
of amendments the Clean Air Act under
the first Bush administration that
allowed for a kind of cap and trade
system that to deal with the problem of
acid rain and those were seen as a
widely seen as being successful and so I
think that this this historical analogy
is now being applied to the current
situation where although many economists
thinks that attacks would be a better
solution to the carbon dioxide emissions
problem it's seen as political suicide
and so sort of dead in the water okay so
you are seeing patterns particularly in
the political arena that may persist
moving forward or or not well I think
there are a lot there are a lot of
patterns and I guess I let me just
extend a little bit some of the ways in
which histories is being used first I
wanted to mention also that I think you
could you can make the argument that
that some of the reasons why climate
legislation hasn't moved forward in the
United States is that has to do with
some of the dominant historical myths so
I think this is another historical a
role for historians as to address some
of these myths and one of those is the
is the idea that the energy market is a
free market and that the dominance of
fossil fuels in the economy today is
Israel Israel
alt of just free competition among
industries and and fuels over the last
century and I think a historical
perspective allows us to see that the
role of the role the government played
over the last hundred years whether it
was in tax policy or questions over
property rights or also regulation if
you think of the role the Texas Railroad
Commission in ascending energy setting
oil prices in many ways in the United
States so I think 11 contribution
historians can make is the is really to
explode the idea that there is a free
market and energy and to help people to
understand that energy has always been a
social part of a social process that's
politically negotiated so as you're
asking about what some of the political
trends are I think it's important to see
that the political trends of the past
are likely to continue into the future
and so a few of those important ones one
is that the that there is a set of rules
and regulations that get set for a
dominant fuel of such as oil and that
those then help that fuel sort of get
entrenched in to the economic landscape
so examples of that might be just a
small detail of that would be the
competition between street cars and
automobiles in the city so one so this
is an interesting story because street
cars used to be the dominant
transportation but at some point cars
became more popular and and there was a
decision that the street cars would have
to give way to automobiles and
automobiles could slow down in front of
them and they could kind of clogged up
the roadway and then there was also a
decision that the street cars paid taxes
and those taxes would go to the
government which would then go to fund
the streets which would then be there to
support the automobiles and so it's a
bit of a complicated story but I think
that the main point is that rules and
regulations are strongly associated with
the dominant fuel knows will change and
I think one thing that we can expect to
see over the coming generation really is
that these rules and regulations will
change there was a article SI recently a
collection of articles recently in New
York Times that I think was kind of
interesting it was entitled uh I think
it was a tough week for coal
and it contained a series of these kinds
of rules and regulations that were being
reversed whether it was permits for
coal-fired power plants or permit the
right to dump certain kinds of mining
wastes and all those things and those
are the kinds of things are the kinds of
rules and regulations that will change
in the future okay let's continue
looking at the governmental aspect of it
do you think that states and nations can
work together to create some kind of
climate policy yeah well I mean that's a
that's really one of the most
challenging issues that society faces
today I mean if you think about at the
state level of state governments in the
United States it's clear that there are
there is an ability to collaborate and
in and actually over the last decade or
so it's really been the states that have
been leading the way and also the
localities and I think that's one of the
political insights that historians can
bring to understanding what to expect in
the future which is that climate and
energy policy are set not only at the
national level but also at the local
state and then also international level
so as to whether they can collaborate
well clearly at the state level you have
regional collaborative around greenhouse
gas emission controls right now in the
Northeast for instance and
collaborations over automobile emission
standards at the international level I
think one of the thing that one of the
lessons that historians have to offer
really has to do with how distinctive
the climate problem is from other issues
that we faced in the past and so one
example that well it guess it's how
difficult it is to find an analogy to
climate change and people like to talk
about chlorofluorocarbons and the ozone
layer and how the Montreal Protocol
solve that problem but it was really
much a much narrower issue than the
climate one which really addresses
economic development economic
development across the whole society as
opposed to a few chemicals that can be
taken out of production by a small
number of companies but at the same time
we we have had international agreements
on trade trade organizations
international
security agreements and all those have
involved States you know making
concessions and agreements and
optimistic that we'll be able to come to
an international agreement I think the
ultimate question is going to be one of
implementation and within each country
and that goes returns to my previous
comment which is just that I think it's
critical for everyone to understand that
the climate problem is one that will be
with us for generations as a political
problem that is not one that will be
solved by the passage of a climate bill
in in Congress this session but that
that will really just be the beginning
of a long period of political conflict
over the rules and institutions and
implementation of of those okay so what
are some things the government can do to
spur an energy transition in the coming
years I think the most important single
step the government can take is to find
a way to raise the price of carbon
emissions carbon dioxide and other
related get your greenhouse gas
emissions and there that that can be
justified and kind of explained by
historians if you look by looking at the
past in all the ways the government has
shaped the energy market historically
and and really acted to try to drive
down fossil fuel prices whether it's
through tax policies or property right
property kind of generous property
policies in addition to that I think
that the the government clearly has a
historic role that is played in many
industries the Internet of public
investment of public investment science
as well as public subsidies for new
technologies and a role in trying to
speed innovation and I think that if we
look historically in a series of
different industries including energy
but also other kinds of scientific
breakthroughs the government has played
a critical role in that and I think this
goes back to the the fundamental point
that I wanted to make related to the
idea of a free market energy I think
that this is one of the very problematic
myths that has grown up around the the
dominance of the fossil fuels which is
that it was purely about economic free
economic competition that resulted in
our embrace of fossil fuels to such an
extent
and I think that when you look back at
the history history this is what my
first book was about is you know you see
all the different ways the government
shaped shape the development of the oil
economy and really deepened our
dependence on fossil fuels and so I
think if we understand that the market
in the past has always been a social
market in which politics and social
decisions based on our values have
shaped that market then then we realize
that we face those same kinds of social
decisions today and that is not about
government intervening in the market but
rather making choices that we all in
evitable have to make about what that
energy market is going to look like okay
so using history as a guide in what does
the future hold for us are we going to
go the way of the dodo bird or is there
hope mmm well that's that's a little
hard to I mean I think that the most
important thing to remember is that is
that the climate change problem it's not
really one about human extinction it's
more it's more social problem that as I
was saying about that relates to our
values and the things that we care and
look care about and love and so they
might be things such as peace and
security and justice or even the special
places though that we that we that we
care about that are undergoing rapid
rapid change so I think really the the
response to climate change and this
again is where historians have something
to offer is that it's a social and
cultural problem as and political
problem as much as a technical one so
we're not going to go extinct but we
have choices to make as a society about
what kind of world we're going to live
in in the future very good thanks very
much for being here with us today and
sharing some of your work thank you very
much with pleasure for more information
about professor Saban and his research
please visit our website at Yale dot edu
backslash Macmillan report be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you